former president donald trump is firing
back at his former vice president mike
pence over pence's remarks that he could
have overturned the 2020 presidential
election results
in a statement issued last night mr
trump said pence is playing into the
hands of democrats to get president
biden re-elected this growing divide is
just one piece of what appears to be a
splintered republican party ramping up
for the midterms and the 2024
presidential race
catherine herrich reports
in searing comments about the january
sixth rights the former vice president
took on his old boss president trump
said i had the right to
overturn the election
but president trump is wrong
i had no right to overturn the election
addressing a conservative conference in
florida the public rebuke seemed
especially striking the presidency
belongs to the american people and the
american people alone
and frankly there is no idea more on
american
than the notion that any one person
could choose the american president the
eyes have it in a vote that seems to
symbolize a divide among republicans the
rnc centered adam kinzinger and liz
cheney for serving on the january 6
committee calling it a democrat-led
persecution of ordinary citizens engaged
in legitimate political discourse in
response chaney tweeted video from
january 6 writing this is not legitimate
political discourse
more than 225 people have been charged
for assaulting law enforcement
three weeks before the capital attack
emails and draft orders obtained by cbs
news show president trump's outside
advisers considered authorizing the
secretary of homeland security to seize
all machines another draft order looked
to grant similar powers to the defense
secretary emails indicate the draft
orders were circulated by a former army
colonel phil waldron to a small group
including rudy giuliani former new york
city police commissioner bernie carrick
and trump's former national security
adviser general michael flynn who said
this at the time about the president's
options he could immediately on his
order sees
every single one of these machines
around the country on his order
in that speech pence took direct aim at
president trump saying january 6 was a
dark day and pence seemed to telegraph
his own political ambitions adding that
vice president harris will also have no
authority to overturn the 2024 election
when pence said republicans would win
for cbs saturday morning i'm catherine
herridge in washington